Sadie Robertson reality star fashion
designer ballroom dancer and now she's
an actress starring in the new
faith-based drama
God's not dead - I've been like I didn't
use my way into movies and this is like
the perfect way to do it with something
that's like really mean something to me
so you remember my friend Brooke yeah
well she got a teacher in trouble for
asking her about Jesus the duck dynasty
star along with her mom Corey have never
been shy about having strong Christian
beliefs they told et how their faith has
gotten them through challenging times
faith is a part of our life it gets us
through the good times at the bad time
so I think it's just it permeates every
part of our life definitely doing some
with the Stars and out my faith during
that show I definitely Karen made it
through it was just a crazy experience
and God just really took me away next
the Robertsons are gearing up for a
wedding
Sadie's 27 year old sister Rebecca is
set to tie the knot later this year
she's going to do a destination wedding
but we can't tell where but it will be
cooler tropical yes and I'm the whole
family's really excited about it as for
18 year old Sadie's love life a source
told ET she and her boyfriend Blake
recently split after two years of dating
but it's no big deal
Corey told et last month Sadie is
focused on her career right now oh you
know Sadie's young so we've gotten a lot
of years she's going to focus on and you
know this this movie and on what we're
doing with our dynasty and all the
amazing opportunities she's got going on
right now